doctor las oleadas de omicron están
contagiando a más niños que en las
oleadas anteriores le pregunto entonces
a qué se debe esto
raúl buenos días dentro de la gran
espectro de la contagiosidad que tiene
el coronavirus de la variante de omicron
lo que pasa es que los niños como están
con menor tasa inmunización se infectan
de la misma forma que los adultos pero
muchos de ellos se hacen síntomas es
decir los niños tienen comorbilidades
pueden generar una enfermedad grave por
eso es que vemos en las estadísticas
como los niños son los que menos están
inmunizados los que más casos se
reportan ahora autor sabemos si esta
variante afecta a los niños de alguna
manera distinta
no lo que vemos es que es el
comportamiento similar en los adultos
que puede ser un cuadro de infección
respiratoria leve pero los niños que
tienen moore comorbilidades como por
ejemplo cardiopatías alteraciones
pulmonares en la obesidad es muy muy
importante pueden desarrollar
complicaciones y hospitalizar e incluso
ir a cuidado intensivo por eso es
importante vacunar los ante todo esto
doctor le pregunto si fue prudente haber
reabierto en las escuelas con los
contagios que con lo contagiosa que es
esta variante omicron es seguro para los
niños y para los profesores dr
en la región lo que hemos visto es que
la gran mayoría de países abrieron la
vacunación a niños mayores de tres o de
cinco años más además de eso toda la
población de profesores y administrativa
está vacunada incluso con refuerzo yo
creo que es prudente sin embargo eso hay
que evaluarlo cada dos semanas cómo es
el comportamiento de las escuelas porque
si bien omicron es un problema de salud
pública la salud mental de nuestros
niños la falta de educación y la falta
de acceso a la presencialidad también
tiene un problema de salud pública
entonces el riesgo-beneficio yo creo que
si era conveniente pero es necesario
hablarlo monitorizar los pecho usted
habla de la salud pública le pregunta
entonces las medidas de salud pública
que se deberían implementar desde los
gobiernos para así asegurar un retorno a
las aulas seguro
debe haber vacunación para los niños y
debe haber la preparación de los
biológicos para los niños vemos como hay
preparaciones de las vacunas serranía
para población pediátrica que no están
disponibles en la región eso es
importante debemos propender porque todo
el personal docente administrativo de la
institución tengan el refuerzo de la
vacuna y que sea parte de esto
y que nosotros tengamos la disciplina
social para que en la casa también
mantengamos las medidas que ya hemos
conocido en estos dos años hay que ir a
las aulas hay que vacunarse como medida
de salud pública para contener esta
infección y la población plegat sin
embargo todos varios padres sigan en
recelando de la vacunación a sus hijos
es la mejor manera de protegerlos
definitivamente la vacunación demostró
que evita la mortalidad y es importante
que los padres de familia se les oriente
a ningún niño se le puede impedir el
acceso a la educación por no estar
vacunado lo que hay que hacer es sobre
esa población que no está vacunada y los
niños personalidad los padres a través
de educación a través de el acercamiento
para que los lleven a vacunar
definitivamente necesitamos vacunar
desde los meses de nacido hasta los 99 o
100 años a toda la población para poder
llegar a la inmunidad colectiva que
queremos o por lo menos la fase endémica
de la de la enfermedad doctor pero
todavía que no está autorizado la
vacunación para muchos niños entonces
cómo proteger a estos niños que todavía
no están en edad para vacunarse
algunas vacunas de virus inactivos están
aprobadas después de los 3 años ya hay
estudios clínicos que salen en un par de
meses según los anuncios en donde se va
con una población de un año a 3 años y
de 1 a 5 años en vacunas errónea creo
que al final de este semestre ya habrá
una vacuna para presentación pediátrica
en todas las edades y ahí será muy
importante toda la parte de educación
sin embargo de una gran parte de la
población escolarizada mayor de 5 años
que ya está disponible la vacunación ya
está abierta es el proceso en varios
países así que debemos vacunar estos
niños antes de ir a su colegio